dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here I
apologize for my voice today I am
trapped in this frail human body and
sometimes it falters but the papers must
go on this is one of those papers where
I find that the more time I spend with
it the more I realize how amazing it is
it starts out with an interesting little
value proposition that in and of itself
would likely not make it to a paper so
what is this paper about well as you see
here this one is about Cuba fication of
3d geometry in other words we take an
input shape and it styluses it to look
more like a cube okay that's cute
especially given that there are many
many ways to do this and it's hard to
immediately put into words what a good
end result would be you can see a
comparison to previous works here these
previous works did not seem to preserve
a lot of fine details but if you look at
this new one you see that this one does
that really well very nice indeed but
still when I read this paper at this
point I was thinking I'd like a little
more well i quickly found out that this
work has more up its sleeve so much more
let's talk about seven of these amazing
features for instance one we can control
the strength of the transformation with
this lambda parameter as you see the
more we increase it the more
heavy-handed the smooshing process is
going to get please remember this part
- we can also Cuba fie selectively along
different directions
or select parts of the object that
should be Cuba fide differently hmm okay
three we can even use it to fix flaws in
the input 3d geometry
for this transformation procedure also
takes into consideration the
orientations this means that we can
perform it from different angles which
gives us a large selection of possible
outputs for the same model five it is
fast and works on high resolution
geometry and you see different settings
for the lambda parameter here that is
the same parameter as we talked about
before the strength of the
transformation
six we can also combine many of these
features interactively until a desirable
shape is found seven is about to come in
a moment but to appreciate what that is
we have to look at this to perform what
you have seen here so far we have to
minimize this expression this first term
says AR ap as rigid as possible which
stipulates that whatever we do in terms
of smooshing it should preserve the fine
local features the second part is called
a regularization term that encourages
sparser more axis aligned solutions so
we don't destroy the entire model during
this process the stronger this term is
the bigger say it has in the final
results which in return become more
cube-like so how do we do that well of
course with our trusty little lambda
parameter not only that but if we look
at the appendix it tells us that we can
generalize the second regularization
term for many different shapes so here
we are finally seven it doesn't even
need to be Cuba fication we can specify
all kinds of polyhedra look at those
gorgeous results I love this paper it is
playful it is elegant it has utility and
it generalizes well it doesn't care in
the slightest what the current
mainstream ideas are and invites us into
its own little world in summary this
will serve all your Cuba fication needs
and turns out it might even fix your
geometry and more I would love to see
more papers like this in this series I
try to make people feel how I feel when
I read these papers I hope I have
managed this time but you be the judge
let me know in the comments this episode
has been supported by Linode Linode is
the world's largest independent cloud
computing provider they offer you
virtual servers that make it easy and
affordable to host your own app site
project or anything else in the cloud
whether you are a Linux expert or just
starting to tinker with your own code
Linode will be useful for you a few
episodes ago we played with an
implementation of open
SGP t2 where are excited viewers
accidentally overloaded the system with
Li nodes load balancing technology and
instances ranging from Sheridan anodes
all the way up to dedicated GPUs you
don't have to worry about your project
being overloaded to get $20 of free
credit make sure to head over to lino
comm slash papers and sign up today
using the promo code papers 20 our
thanks to Lee node for supporting the
series and helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time